one phenomenon that there is is the fake
wives modern women are fake wives these
are women that have the title of a wife
that maybe have been married but do not
have the mindset of a wife now the
number one mindset of a wife is nothing
to do with looks it's nothing to do with
fashion it actually has everything to do
with selflessness now I talk a lot about
Botox lip filler hair extensions and
Nails there's nothing wrong with these
things by themselves however typically
the husbands are not the ones pushing
this on their wives the women are
pushing this on themselves in order to
get more attention from other men and
not their husbands